mit dieser maschinen machen wir heute
die fassadenreinigung schon mal den
block aber es fand realisierter wasser
kommt da hier ja oder sich schwarzer
kabel ist von jimmy da kommt da an
geht's weiter
hut ab 3 das wäre so gebaut und sie
schnurrt immer muss zur gedreht werden
damit die kabel nicht hin und her geht
januar findet im wasser auflaufen lassen
einmal mehr starten würde ich
durchdrehen und jetzt geht's los
kurzum ja panik abputzen
also immer wieder kurz vandal die hälfte
fenster gemacht einmal immer kurz zu
machen halter unterbränd
einmal so was machen die genau darauf
dass die geräte aus
auf dem mond
was dann schön auch die fassade
du möchtest kannst du es ja auch noch
machen
jetzt sowie zwei varianten
es sind schlimme auf schwamm das ein
bisschen noch mit leben erster wechsel
denke
jan o
noch mehr aber auch genau richtig so
ich glaube genau
versuchst einmal kreisende bewegung
machen die verkäufer drei
sonderbewegungen kreisende bewegungen
sind besser das ist auch schöning
bohrungen eingibt du bist du
es ist noch etwas
so jetzt der arbeit schon lange beendet
wir sind fertig